l'avvocato luca cordero di montezemolo
bravo è
grazie
allora 30 secondi fuori tempo però 30
perché io volevo ringraziare di questi
invito
volevo dire che sono molto felice dopo
sette anni professor fantoni di tornare
qui di tornare in questa nuova sede
invece
mi fa piacere di incontrare alcune
persone alcuni professori soprattutto di
vedere sempre lo stesso spirito tanti
giovani con un fil rouge di
internazionalità e di interattività
volevo anche dire volevo fare i
complimenti a chi mi ha preceduto mi ha
un po spaventato su alcune cose gli
faccio i complimenti
lui ha fatto e così entriamo adesso
scattano i no perché lui è inflessibile
lo devo stare attentissimo io vi
parlerei per circa due ore due ore e
mezza avevo preparato dei filmati sulla
ferrari sui treni ma detto che non si
può far pubblicità che solo 18 minuti e
che non si sgarra e quindi sono
concentratissimo e parto da lì io devo
dirvi intanto che
arrivando dopo un po di tempo in questa
meravigliosa città e
avendo avuto tra l'altro un incontro
oggi in una delle altre eccellenze
questa città che sono le generali e
venendo qui ho detto che bel paese che
l'italia paese bello esteticamente
e paese
basta vedere arrivando qui cos'è trieste
e paese pieno di eccellenze questa è
un'eccellenza non eccellenza forte
un'eccellenza vera è un'eccellenza
internazionale che ha però un forte
radicamento su questo territorio questa
è una delle grandi cose e che
caratterizzano le eccellenze del nostro
paese vedete
innovazione io sono contento di parlare
di innovazione e vi dico subito
chi mi ha preceduto gli faccio ancora i
complimenti ha fatto vedere due bambini
io ho un bambino di un anno e mezzo
l'altro giorno un signore ha detto alla
moglie mentre mi vedeva con il bambino
che è caduto per terra perché camminava
male toh guarda montezemolo è un bravo
imprenditore ma quella che bravo nonno e
allora gli ho detto guardi che ha
sbagliato di più posso allora pensiamo
lui diceva dove eravamo dieci anni
quando saremo dieci anni avanti o
vi volevo far riflettere su alcune cose
vedete io sono nato nel dopoguerra già
una grande privilegio una grande fortuna
in cui in italia nel mondo
c'erano quattro grandi potenze gli stati
uniti la germania e l'italia usciti
dalla guerra e il giappone la mia
infanzia è stata assegnata dal terrore
dei giapponesi avrebbero conquistato
tutto avrebbero cambiato tutto chissà
cosa sarebbe successo
abbiamo visto che abbiamo perso qualche
azienda di elettronica perché forse la
gestivamo male ma che in fondo non è
cambiato niente
oggi se noi guardiamo dove eravamo dieci
anni fa 2002 e dove siamo oggi il mondo
la tecnologia le abitudini l'innovazione
la crescita di certi paesi la il crollo
di altri il cambiamento di leaders la
nascita di nuovi prodotti di nuove
metodologie le scoperte scientifiche
dieci anni che un po di tempo fa
sarebbero stati 20 30 o addirittura 40
il mondo va velocissimo
ecco perché il concetto di innovazione e
forse qualche cosa che vorrei dire che
in termini provocatori dovrebbe stare è
scritto in mezzo alla bandiera italiana
dove c'è il bianco innovazione
innovazione a 360 gradi innovazione di
cultura dalla prima elementare
innovazione nel modo di pensare
innovazione nel modo di organizzare io
appartengo ad una generazione che ha
guardato molto al prodotto ha guardato
molto al processo e quando sono
diventato presidente confindustria mi
ricordo la mia prima relazione parlare
di ricerca e capivo la fondamenta le
dicevo che un paese che non investe in
ricerca e un paese che non investe nel
futuro
vedevo negli occhi di tanti anche
colleghi imprenditori cioè ma come vuol
altro parliamo di cose più concrete di
cose più reali
l'innovazione non è solo il prodotto non
è solo il processo ci mancherebbe altro
che un qualunque imprenditore un
qualunque team non lavorasse in maniera
forte e innovativa in maniera
determinata sul prodotto e sul processo
d'innovazione per me è un modo di
intendere la propria vita
l'innovazione è un qualche cosa che deve
entrare nel dna di un paese in questo
caso dell'italia dalla prima elementare
e deve rappresentare un qualche cosa con
cui si affronta la vita non solo a
livello professionale
vedete se io guardo nel mio mestiere
cosa vuol dire innovazione
elencandoli in in tanti temi pensate
all'innovazione che riguarda la cosa più
importante di un imprenditore le donne e
gli uomini che lavorano in azienda il
più grande patrimonio innovazione vuol
dire innovazione nella formazione
innovazione nella nel tracciato di
carriera innovazione nel modo di
lavorare
innovazione nell'organizzazione
innovazione nello nel team spirit
innovazione nel affrontare sfide
condivise in cui ognuno deve dare il suo
contributo senza one man show ma
attraverso un insieme di competenze
specifiche che si mettono insieme per
risultato unico
non parlo di prodotto
se io vedo le automobili negli ultimi
dieci anni e non è solo un discorso di
elettronica di gadget o di interni parlo
di di prestazioni di consumi di co2
parlo di
sicurezza parlo di durabilità parlo di
peso parlo di innovazione nei name nei
materiali parlo innovazione nel design
parlo l'applicazione della galleria del
vento e denaro dinamico in funzione dei
consumi della sicurezza e anche delle
prestazioni non vi voglio parlare del
mio mestiere in formula 1 perché lì si
starebbe male perché l'innovazione in
formula 1 è talmente esasperata in certi
modi anche talmente folle che porta a
far sì che oggi una macchina di formula
1 ossia un aereo girato dall'altra parte
in cui l'areodinamica diventa
fondamentale in cui la competenza per la
progettazione della macchina non ha
niente a che fare con quello
dell'automobile ma viene dal satellite
viene dell'aeronautica addirittura dallo
spaziale
25 minuti non 18 allora per quanto
riguarda il tema dell'innovazione
io credo che in una sede come questa in
cui la ricerca scientifica che è
fondamentale in funzione della ricerca
applicata che è un continuo
miglioramento nel anche con se stessi
del cercare di guardare avanti va bene
in una sede come questa io non posso
mettermi a parlare di innovazione o di
ricerca scientifica perché sarei
assolutamente incompetente
però voglio parlare di innovazione nel
senso di cosa vuol dire oggi per un
giovane per un imprenditore per uno
studente per chiunque trovarsi di fronte
a la cosa più bella che sta dietro
all'innovazione la creatività vedete
quando io parlo di
creatività
parlo di un qualche cosa che vuol dire
competenza curiosità vuol dire
determinazione vuol dire ambiente un
ambiente un sistema paese un environment
che favorisca la
creatività e l'applicazione della
creatività qual è la cosa più bella per
un imprenditore
trasferire l'idea trasferire in su un
sogno in un prodotto finito in
un'azienda in qualcosa di tangibile la
creatività vuol dire anche avere le
condizioni avere gli strumenti avere la
competenza avere la possibilità di
applicarla con dietro la passione qual è
la differenza tra dei straordinari
prodotti tedeschi ci sono delle macchine
le straordinarie
magnifiche che sembrano dei frigoriferi
non si rompano mai freddi perfette poca
emozione fanta e le vetture italiane
alcune come quelle rosse la passione la
tecnologia calda rispetto alla
tecnologia fredda e dietro la creatività
che si unisce con la passione con la
determinazione con la sfida con la
voglia di fare sempre qualcosa di meglio
e di più l'innovazione però assumendo
che il prodotto sia eccezionale vuol
dire anche la capacità per molte aziende
di lavorare con i migliori partners con
i migliori centri di ricerca lo col
migliore università quindi attirare
all'interno del proprio stabilimento del
proprio ambiente
l'afp l'aria fresca in giro per il mondo
attraverso i contatti con le tecnologie
attraverso però un rapporto continuo
costante con i migliori fornitori
migliori centri di ricerca ecco perché è
fondamentale
inculcare il concetto in cui
l'innovazione non è solo sul prodotto
pensate all'organizzazione io spesso
sento dei colleghi imprenditori mi
dicono luca finalmente stasera ho finito
la riorganizzazione della mia azienda io
gli dico guarda domattina alle 7 devi
ricominciare perché l'organizzazione
vuol dire innovazione vuol dire mettere
migliori condizioni per lavorare vuol
dire lavorare sul tailor made sulle
singole persone non attraverso solo il
genoma che mi spaventa anche un po e
quindi faccio finta di non guardarlo ma
perché poi quando si comincia a parlare
di genomi come quando uno entra da un
meccanico per cambiare le candele poi ti
guardano tutta la macchina e scopri che
devi cambiare un sacco di cose allora mi
preoccupa però l'innovazione nel senso
della capacità di affrontare tanti temi
pensate il marketing pensate
l'innovazione nel marketing negli ultimi
dieci anni non aiuti 30 anni nella
capacità di affrontare i mercati nella
capacità di comunicare nella capacità
dal packaging spesso
l'innovazione la creatività sul
packaging cambia i contenuti di un
prodotto ea parità di condizioni la
capacità di innovare nei materiali nei
disegni nei colori
nel nel presentare il prodotto al
cliente guardate l'evoluzione dei
display nei grandi magazzini negli
ultimi dieci anni guardate la pubblicità
guardate i nuovi strumenti di
comunicazione
guardate la raffinatezza con cui si
affrontano target sempre più specifici e
differenti non è più solo uomo e donna
un giovane anziano c'è una segmentazione
di target pazzeschi pensate
all'innovazione nell'affrontare i nuovi
mercati
nell'organizzazione delle reti di
vendita nella formazione
quando c'è una un'azienda che esporta in
50 60 70 paesi del mondo vuol dire
innovare nell'anticipare i trend i gusti
dei singoli paesi nel preparare prodotti
colori dettagli e particolari del del
prodotto in funzione dei singoli paesi
non si fa più dei prodotti evergreen
valida in tutto il mondo pensate
l'innovazione nella qualità della vita
in fabbrica io ho una delle più grandi
soddisfazioni che ha avuto nella mia
vita è stato quello di vincere come la
ferrario il premio the best place to
work in europe qualità della vita
motivazione orgoglio delle persone
capacità di lavorare insieme metodo ma
anche passione ma anche il mettere al
centro di ogni investimento nel processo
non tanto l'evoluzione tecnologica che
l'udc che è fondamentale e ci
mancherebbe altro ma la qualità
dell'ambiente si fa innovazione nei nel
nella cromati d'azione degli ambienti si
fa innovazione nell'aria nei nel nella
luce è
fondamentale oggi affrontare qualunque
tema con un grande spirito di
innovazione
io non devo fare pubblicità e non la
faccio però
nel lavoro che ho l'onore e la fortuna
di affrontare io cerco sempre di
guardare avanti nel senso di non solo
fare un grande bench marking su aziende
diverse su aziende di prodotti mercati
particolarità particolarità diverse ma
soprattutto nel cercare di dare un
qualche cosa di diverso al consumatore
finale
nel mondo oggi per esempio dei treni dei
trasporti ferroviari che il futuro di
questo paese
quando si decideranno a liberalizzare
davvero rendere competitivo tutto
pensate che cosa vuol dire oggi un
innovazione in termini di silenzio di
comfort in termini di minor di rapidità
di contatti in termini di utilizzo delle
tecnologie al bordo del treno dico
queste cose perché voi lavorate su
ricerca scientifica che la conditio sine
qua non è il futuro e la frontiera su
cui che che precede e poi la ricerca
applicata ma vedete io mi trovo per
mille motivi a lavorare
con un'innovazione che lo ripeto fino
alla noia dà per scontato il prodotto
io faccio degli esempi vivevo negli
stati uniti negli anni 70 e c'erano due
grandi marchi di dentifrici col gate e
crest in altri paesi sarebbero finiti
oggi l'innovazione che loro fanno se voi
guardate come era il packaging il
prodotto o le caratteristiche 10 dieci
anni fa e oggi sono due mondi
completamente diversi ma credo che la
sostanza è stata una grande capacità di
marketing denti bianchi denti fini
bambini medietà a donne e uomini i
migliori dentisti del mondo te lo
consigliano sto dicendo che secondo me
dietro al termine innovazione c'è una
grandissima forza di creatività ma c'è
anche la forza di un paese nel credere
nella credibilità nel credere nelle
start up nel credere nelle idee nel
supportare le idee nello scommettere in
altre parole cultura dell'innovazione
dovrebbe essere trasversale dalla prima
elementare in tutte le aree di un paese
soprattutto un paese che ha della grande
forza naturale di dna di creatività che
non è solo la moda il design con tutto
rispetto fornici oro food ma e
tecnologia sapete qual è oggi in
giappone l'export numero uno italiano
con tutto rispetto non sono né
automobili nei food nel design e
meccanica di precisione
dietro la meccanica di precisione c'è
un'evoluzione continua se io guardo i
nostri motori come sono oggi come erano
dieci anni fa in termini di peso intervi
consumi in termini di dinamica in
termini anche di capacità di utilizzare
degli strumenti innovativi
nel setup nel nello sviluppo e nella
affidabilità del motore parlo per
esempio dei banchi prove quindi parlo di
processo
vedete io credo che se noi guardiamo se
noi guardiamo
all'innovazione e ne facciamo un
tormentone che stimola la la qualità
della vita che stimola il anche gli
studenti anche i bambini
io giustamente chi mi ha preceduto c'è
cosa saranno i nostri figli quando
avranno la nostra età quando avrà la mia
età se addirittura non so se remo nel
3000 però dico il tema è il mondo va
così veloce che le non scelte di oggi le
pagheremo carissime non tra trent'anni
tra cinque o dieci anni io
quando ero presidente della fiat andavo
tre volte l'anno in brasile fino a un
anno fa
dieci anni fa il brasile era un paese
che era conosciuto per le belle donne
per il carnevale per il calcio e per le
favelas è un paese che cresce a doppia
cifra è un paese giovane impresa
innovativa un paese che fa ricerca è un
paese che ha delle università
all'avanguardia e un paese che ha fatto
ultimamente dei grandi passi avanti
basandosi sull'innovazione allora io
dico se noi guardiamo tante eccellenze
del nostro paese che ci fanno onore
prendiamo non solo la tecnologia
prendiamo per esempio la ricerca la
medicina io ho l'onore o la
responsabilità ho il piacere di fare il
presidente di telethon che collabora
molto nella ricerca con la sissa ed è
malattie genetiche ed è il discorso di
affrontare una miriade di malattie che
colpiscono
fondamentalmente i bambini e cosa c'è
alla base della ricerca
c'è la competenza
c'è il merito merito un paese che deve
saper premiare chi è più bravo
attraverso delle valutazioni vere
attraverso dei premi veri attraverso una
trasparenza ecco la ricerca di telethon
quello di rispondere a questi bambini
che sono bambini di tutto il mondo che
fanno oggi un viaggio della speranza al
contrario non più dall'italia verso
l'estero
dall'estero verso in italia grazie alla
qualità della ricerca italiana ricerca
scientifica di ricercatori di qualità
che vengono selezionati premiati e
valutati attraverso commissioni
internazionali che cambiano ogni anno e
che mel e che mettono il merito al
centro di ogni
valutazione e quindi quando noi vediamo
il sorriso di questi bambini ci
accorgiamo di una cosa di nuovo della
passione della forza della tecnologia
calda di come affrontiamo e di come
affrontate un mestiere un'attività
straordinaria che non solo ha delle
grandi valenze scientifiche a delle
valenze di grande impegno alle valenze
di studio a delle valenze di
applicazione ma che ha dietro di sé e
questo il mio messaggio
passione in quello che si fa coraggio
idee visioni e soprattutto quello quando
si è un imprenditore o un capo
dimettersi vicino persone molto più
bravi di di sé molto più capaci e di
metterle nelle migliori condizioni per
vincere per avere successo e per
trascinare verso il futuro sulla base di
innovazione qualunque impresa
imprenditoriale grazie a tutti
allora